you've heard right we all hate Facebook
I hate that I always see the same as I
hate the Facebook decides but I get only
the political crap I'm not a lady so no
sir and I really don't care what you're
listening to on Spotify yeah and don't
forget the insanely cluttered menus and
interface but here's the thing if we
hated Facebook that much we'd all stop
using it and I don't think that's gonna
happen so the best thing we can do suck
it up and try and make it better
after hearing over 500 complaints from
readers in the last week I decided to
show you how to deal with the biggest
headaches no there's nothing I can do
about your mom being on Facebook Joanna
did you see your cousin's pound
throwback Thursday
anyway I promise by the end of this
video you'll hate Facebook a little bit
less okay complaint number one I keep
seeing stuff I don't care about in my
newsfeed sometimes multiple times just
last week Facebook announced a way to
prioritize posts from the most important
people in your life
go to your friends page click see first
and their posts will pop up at the very
top from now on but a browser plug-in
called social fixer goes way further
hiding posts about specific topics you
don't want to see and if you hate
Facebook's top stories feed the tool can
set the chronological most recent feed
as your default next I dislike that
there's no dislike button okay until
mark here decides that he wants to add
one I have two workarounds for this to
tell Facebook you don't like something
click here on a post and then select
hide post you can then even tell
Facebook why you didn't like it if you
want to tell someone publicly you don't
like something in a post you can use
this dislike sticker in a comment I hate
the constant notifications seriously I
don't want to get a notification every
time someone comments on a post that I
commented on after you comment in a post
click here and then turn off
notifications
go into settings and then notifications
to turn off pop-ups about specific games
and apps complaint for advertising
you're not gonna get rid of it all but
you can make it a little bit better you
can get rid of those ads on the right
rail with a browser extension like
Facebook ad blocker as for the sponsored
posts in the newsfeed
you can tell Facebook why you don't like
a specific ad you can also go to about
ads info / choices on your computer to
stop web tracking so you don't see ads
after visiting another site ok so it
isn't perfect in here and fixing it up
takes quite a bit of work but there sure
is a lot less to hate and quite a bit
more to like